I am Dr D from bandi
college
well every religion is a supreme science
of
life nothing is wrong so far as the
principles of religions are
concerned but the formulation of
principles is a different thing and
execution of these principles is a
different
thing actually where there is no
relationship of blood
the relationship is to be established by
the
religions actually what we
find I
quote but actually what we find what we
realize what we experience is this the
maximum blood is vested only on account
of the conflicts in the
religions so where is the wrong I mean
what are your views about
this how would you reconcile the
principles of religion and this chaos
which arises on account of religion what
are your views on on this particular
aspect Prophet has asked a very good
question that in all religion basically
speak good things but the implementation
may be different they teach good things
but today you see in the world many
people are fighting on the name of
religion how can you solve this problem
it's a very good question and part of
the answer I gave in my talk and I said
that as far as Islam is concerned we
should not kill any human being s ma
5:32 how can you situ it
that we can come to Common terms how can
we solve the differences that also I
mentioned my talk in Surah Al Imran chap
3 verse 64 which says
that that come to come in terms as us
and you if suppose you have 10 points
and I have got 10 points if out of those
10 points if five points are common and
five are different I at least agree with
those five points which are
coming the differences will come to it
later on Quran
says that come to come in terms as in us
and you which is the first
term that we worship none but
Allah that we associate no partners with
him so you rightly said how to solve and
have given the methodology how to solve
that come to come in terms but the point
to be noted here is that many people who
follow religions they do not know what
their own religion scriptures speak that
is the problem many Muslims don't know
what the Quran and say had speak many
Hindus don't know what Hindu scriptures
say many Christians and Jews don't know
what the Bible says who's to blame
followers therefore I tell the people
you read your
scriptures the point of difference will
come to it later on at least come to the
communalities I've given a talk on
similarities between Islam and
Christianity I say the things which we
differ will come to it later on at least
what your Bible and my Quran says let's
agree with those those things which are
common fight will be solved what I'm
doing now in my talk did I ever
criticize any
religion I was forced to reply when
certain Brothers tried to ask certain
question which I have to speak the truth
otherwise in my talk you can take the
video C said I did not criticize a
single point on any religion I never
spoke about the
differences I only came to Common terms
differences I can give a talk on
differences between Islam Hinduism
difference between Islam and
Christianity I'm a student of
comparative
religion I can quote verses
alhamdulillah from the various World
scriptures talking about differences I
keep that when required when someone
tries to disrupt the program we have to
be very aware of these things but I
never use it in my talk I never use it
to the common man I tell the common man
you read your scriptures you will come
closer to your scriptures and to
Universal Brotherhood read your
scriptures at least first believe in one
God the difference will come to later on
the differen will come to later on
Judaism says that Christianity says that
Hinduism says that Islam says that sism
says that parm says that believe in one
God and worship him alone why do you
worship other gods come to that point
then come to other points if we solve
this problem of commonalities if even if
there are three points common out of 10
at least agree on those common points
the other points we can agree to
disagree we'll come to it later on so if
we come on the common points first
coming on the compar studies believe me
most of the problem will be solved
believe me and that's what I'm doing I'm
going throughout the world and I address
Allin of non-muslims and many of them
because they're not aware of their
scriptures of our scriptures many people
post questions even Muslims aren't aware
of the scriptures so they Poe questions
which they aren't aware of so I educate
them I educate them about Quran about
Hadith about Vedas about Bible and I
quote when I quote I give the reference
number so no one can say oh Zak is ping
a fast one and all these scriptures are
quoted it's available in the Islamic
Research Foundation our library has the
various translation of vas we have
hundreds of types of Bibles more than 30
different versions of the Bibles we have
alhamdulillah so whichever sect you
belong to whether joah Witnesses or
Protestant or Catholic I speak from
their scriptures so if you say that Zak
is wrong you have to say that the Holy
scripture is wrong I quote and most of
my talks are quotations quotations from
various scriptures if you disagree with
the
scriptures that's your choice if you
want to disagree most disagree Quran
says like there's no compulsion religion
truth stands out clear from error so I'm
presenting the truth of Hinduism to you
if you want to agree agree don't want
don't agree there is a symposium the
third cassette from there Symposium on
concept of God on Islam Hinduism
Christianity people may call it a debate
the Hindu p
from k cut a Christian father of cut and
I myself presented the Islamic view four
and a half hours debate it's available
outside Scholars of Hinduism of
Christianity I'm just a student I'm
presenting my view and it's for the
audience to judge I'm talking about
similarities quoting their scriptures
chapter number verse number chapter
number verse number the best way to
cause all the human beings to unite is
find the commonalities speak about the
differences later on hope that answer
the question the next question would be
from the slip then if the sister will
allow uh there one Raj motra he's asking
if Islam is a religion of Peace then how
come it was spread by the
sword the question posed was if Islam is
a religion of Peace how come it was
sprad by the
sword Islam comes from the root toward
Salam which means peace it also means
means submitting of will to Allah
subhana tala almighty God in short Islam
means peace acquired by submitting of
will to Allah subhana wa tala but as I
mentioned earlier that everyone in the
world does not want peace to Prevail in
the world there are certain antisocial
elements for their own benefits they
don't want peace to Prevail the robbers
the criminal if peace will prevail they
will go out of business so for their own
benefit there are certain human beings
who don't want peace to Prevail so for
such types of people Force may have to
be used therefore we have police Etc so
Islam is for peace but sometimes you may
have to use Force to put the antisocial
elements in their place and the best
answer to this question that Islam was
sped by the sword is given by Dei oeri
he's a non-muslim historian of great
repute in his book Islam at the
Crossroad on page number 80 says that
history makes it clear that the legend
of fanatical Muslims sweeping across the
world forcing Islam at the point of the
sword over conquered races is the most
fantastic absurd myth that historians
have ever repeated Dei page number eight
book Islam at the
Crossroad I'm asking a question that we
Muslims we ruled Spain for about 800
years later on the Crusaders came and
they wiped out the Muslims there was not
a Muslim who could openly give the aan
the call for
prayers we didn't use any Force you know
we Muslims we ruled the Arab lands for
about 1400 years for a few years the
britishers came for a few years the
French came but overall the Muslims were
the lordship of the Arab land for 1400
years do you know today there are 14
million Arabs who are Coptic Christians
Coptic Christian means they're
Christians in Generations
since
Generations if the Muslims wanted they
could have converted every non-muslim at
the point of the sword we didn't do
it the 14 million Arabs or Coptic
Christians are giving witness that Islam
wasn't Spar By The Sword you know India
India was ruled for hundreds of years by
the
Muslims we didn't use the sword we
didn't use the sword if few people do a
wrong thing you can't catch up those
people and blame the religion for that
if few people people don't follow the
religion you can't say that Christianity
is bad because Hitler inated 6 million
Jews if Hitler insuated 6 million jewels
burned 6 million jewels you can't blame
Christianity for that there may be Black
Ships in every Community but we Muslims
we ruled India for hundreds of
years if he wanted we could have forced
every non-muslim to convert the point of
the sword we didn't do it the
non-muslims of India Today more than 80%
they are giving shahada they are giving
witness you not non-muslims present here
are giving witness that Islam was ins
sped by the
sword we are giving witness we had the
power we didn't do it Islam doesn't
believe in that today the country which
has the maximum number of Muslims is
Indonesia which Muslim Army went to
Malaysia which has 55% population of
Muslims which Muslim Army went to the
east coast of Africa which Muslim Army
which thought Thomas kalle gives the
reply Thomas kalle he writes in his book
hero and he worship that you have to get
the sword little good will it do that he
should spread with the sword every new
opinion initially begins in the mind of
one one man in the whole world one man
against all the human beings it will do
little good that he picks up a sword and
propagates it which sword even if we had
the sword we can't use it even if we had
the matal sword we can't use it Quran
says in Surah Bak ch
256 there is no compulsion religion
truth stands out clear from error anyone
who grasps the hands of Allah subhana
tala and rejects the evil he has held
the most strong handhold that never
breaks anyone who believes in Allah
Allah will take him from Darkness to
light anyone who believes in the evil
the Satan one he will take him from
lightness to
dark which sword sword of the intellect
Quran says in 16
125 invite all the way of th Lord with
wisdom and beautiful preaching and argue
with them and reason with them in the
ways that are best and most gracious
there was article that came in the plain
truth magazine it was the reproduction
of the reader dig maner book 1986 it
gave the statistics of the increase of
the world religion between 1934 to
1984 in the 50 years number one increase
in major religion was Islam
235% 235% I'm asking you which war took
place between 1934 and 1984 which
converted millions of non-muslims to
Islam which war do you know today the
fastest growing religion in America is
Islam who is forcing the Americans to
convert the point of the sword the
fastest growing religion in Europe is
Islam who's forcing the the point of the
sword Quran gives the answer in no less
than three different places in Surah
chapter number 9 verse number 33 in
Surah sa CH 61 verse number 9 and Surah
fat CH 48 verse 28 the Glorious Quran
says Allah says that Allah has sent his
messenger with
truth and with guidance so that it will
prevail over all the other ways of life
over all the other ISM Islam is destined
to suped all all master them all
overcome them
all enough is Allah as a witness and I
like to end this answer by giving the
quotation of Adam Pearson Dr Adam
Pearson said that people who fear that
one day nuclear weaponry will fall in
the hands of the Arabs they fail to
realize that the Islamic bomb has
already been dropped it fell the day
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him was
born
uh there's a question from Brother Sunil
he asked
when Islam preaches Universal
Brotherhood then how come Muslim
themselves are divided into
sex the question POS is that when Islam
preach Universal Brotherhood how come
Muslims are divided into various sees
the answer is given the Glorious Quran
in Surah Al Imran chapter number three
verse Number 103 it
says hold to the Rope of Allah strongly
and be not divided which is the Rope of
Allah the Glorious Quran is the Rope of
Allah subhana wa tala it says that the
Muslims should hold to the Rope of Allah
the Glorious Quran and the had and they
should not be divided and the Quran says
as I mentioned earlier in Surah Anam
chapter 6 verse 159 that anyone who
divides the religion into sex you have
nothing to do with him Allah will tell
him about the Affairs on the day of
judgment that means it is prohibited for
anyone to make sex of Islam but when you
ask certain Muslim what are you some say
I'm a hanfi some say I'm a Shafi some
say I'm a ham some say I'm a Malaki what
was the Beloved Prophet was he Shafi was
he hum was he Maliki what was he he was
a
Muslim the Quran says in Surah Al Imran
3: 52 that Jesus peace be upon the
3 verse number 67 that abraam was a
Muslim and what was the Beloved Prophet
you are the Muslim
the Quran says inah 41 verse number
33 who is better in speech than one who
invites people to the way of thy Lord
Works righteousness and says I'm of
those who bow to the will of Allah those
who say I'm a Muslim so when anyone POS
the question what are you you should say
I'm a Muslim I have no objection if
someone says I believe in certain
verdicts certain views given by great
Scholars like Abu hanifah Imam Shafi IM
Malik Ahmed H may Allah be pleased with
them all I respect all these great
Scholars if someone agrees with certain
views of Imam Shafi sometimes may Allah
please with him sometimes Abu hanifa may
Allah please with him I've got no
objection but if anyone put the question
what are you you should say you're a
Muslim and as the brother said earlier
that Quran says there'll be 73 sects
what is referring to is saying of
beloved Prophet it's mentioned in Abu
daud Hadith number 4579 it says that the
religion of Islam will be divided into
73 sects but if you note the wording of
the Prophet Muhammad sallallah Ali
wasallam Muhammad peace be upon him he
said that the religion will be divided
he didn't say you should divide the
religion he's prophesizing though the
Quran say don't be divided the Muslims
are bound to divide and there's another
Hadith which mentioned Hadith number 171
the Beloved Prophet said there will be
73 FAS 73 sex
and all will go to hell except for one
and the companion asked which one the
prophet said the one that is on the path
of the prophet and the companions one
that follows the Quran and the
say so anyone who follows the Quran and
Hadith on the true path Islam doesn't
believe in division every person he's a
Muslim anyone who follows the Quran say
a Muslim and Islam is against dividing
the religion into sects and Division
so if you read the Quran and had Muslims
should be United on the basis of Quran
and say had hope they answer the
question yes brother we'll allow two
questions before we have the impressions
of our chief guests and the presidential
address by Advocate hingorani yes
brother I am a retired teacher lakas
guruji I want to ask what is the exact
remedy to increase the universal
Brotherhood for which subject just we
have to give
priority either for
religion or
sociology or politics Will you tell me
please kindly what
is the brother asked a question that
what is the priority to spread Universal
Brotherhood is it religion is it
sociology is it dealing with politics
brother I've given the talk based on
that full topic I don't have to repeat
the same thing man will be same the
priority to spread Universal Brotherhood
in all the religions is to believe in
one God and worship him alone that is
the basic priorities I've repeated that
in the talk I've repeated in aners to
several question and I'm repeating it
again the basic priority is not
sociology or politics that come later on
politics deals with bre out which is
limited sociology which is limited
believe in one God is universal he is
the one who created all human beings
whether male or female whether black or
white whether rich or poor so if you
believe in one God and worship him alone
then there will only be Universal
Brotherhood hope the question the next
question think is something
connected one brother pru is asking all
the religions basically preach good
things thus a person can follow any one
of the religion it is one and the
same the question POS is that all the
religion basically teach good
things so you can follow any religion
it's one and the same and I do agree
with him in the first part of the
question that all religions do basically
preach good things for example all
religion say you should not rob you
should not molest a woman you should not
rap her Hinduism says that Christianity
says that Islam says that but the
difference between Islam and the other
religions is that Islam besides speaking
of good things it shows you a way how to
implement those good things
like all religions speak about
Brotherhood but Islam practically shows
you it demonstrates how to practice it
in your dayto life Salah Haj Etc so
Islam besides speaking theoretically it
shows you a way how to practice it in
your
life for example Hinduism says you
should not Rob Christianity says you
should not Rob Islam says you should not
Rob so what's the difference between
Islam and the other religions Islam
shows you a way how to achieve that
state in which people will not rob
Islam has a system of zakat that is
every rich person who has a saving of
more than the nisab level 85 grams of
gold he or she should give 2.5% of that
excess wealth in charity every lunar
year if every Rich human being gives
charity poverty will be eradicated from
this world there will not be a single
human being will die of
hunger after this the Glorious Quran
says in Surah MAA chapter number five
verse number 38 as to the thief be it a
man or a woman chop of his or her hand
as a punishment from Allah subhana tala
some people may say chopping off the
hands in this age of 20th century Islam
is a barbaric religion it's a ruthless
law and I do know that there are
thousands of people who rob so if you
chop off all the people then many people
lose their hands but the law is so
strict that the moment you implement it
and if a person comes to to know that
his hands will be chopped off if he robs
immediately the thought of robbing will
go away from his mind do you know today
America which happens to be one of the
most advanced country in the world
unfortunately it also has one of the
highest rates of
crime highest rate of robbery and theft
I'm asking you question if you implement
the Islamic Sharia in America that is
every rich person gives zakat 2.5% of
his excess wealth in charity and after
that if any man or woman drops chop of
of her hand I asking you question will
the rate of robbery and theft in America
will it
increase will it remain the same or will
it
decrease it will decrease it's a
practical law you implement the Sharia
and you get results let me give you
another
example that most of the major religion
say that you should not molest a woman
that you should not rape a woman
Hinduism says that Christianity says
that Islam says the same but Islam shows
you a way how to achieve that state in
which people will not men will not
molest or rape a women Islam has a
system of hijab people normally talk
about hijab for the woman but Allah
subhah wa ta'ala in the Glorious Quran
first speaks about the hijab for the man
and then for the woman the Glorious
Quran says in Surah chapter number 24
verse number 30 that said to the
believing man that he should lower his
gaze and guard his modesty whenever a
man looks at a woman and any Brazen
thought comes in his mind any unashamed
thought comes in his mind he should
lower his
gaze there was once a friend of mine was
a Muslim friend who was staring at a
girl for a long time so I told him
brother what are you
doing it's prohibited in Islam to stare
at a girl so he told me our beloved
Prophet said that the first glance is
allowed the second is prohibited I have
not yet completed half my
glance what did the prophet mean by
saying the first Dan is allowed the
second is prohibited he didn't mean that
you can look at a woman and stay Contin
at her for 20 minutes without blinking
what the prophet meant that if you look
at a woman unintentionally intentionally
don't look at her again don't Feast on
her that's for the prophet men the next
verse speaks about the hijab for the
woman Sur 24:31 says that say to the
believing woman that she should lower
her gaze and guard her modesty and
display not her beauty except what
appears ordinary off and to draw a head
covering over the bosen and displ a
Beauty except in front of her husband
her fathers her sons Etc and a big list
of maram the close relatives who she
can't marry is given and there are
basically six criterias for hijab the
first is the extent which differs
between the man and the woman for the
man the extent is from the NV to the
knee for the woman the complete body
should be covered the only part that can
be seen are the face and the hands up to
the wrist some Scholars say even this
should be
covered the remaining five criteria are
the same the second is the clothes they
we it should not be so tight that it
reveals the figure third it should not
be transparent so that you can see
through fourth it should not be So
Glamorous that it attracts opposite sex
fifth it should not resemble that of the
unbeliever sixth it should not resemble
that of the opposite sex these are
basically six criteria for hijab
mentioned in the Quran and the and the
Quran says inab CH 33 verse number 59
giving the reason for hijab it says oh
Prophet tell your Vives and the
believing women that when they go abroad
they should put on the
cloak so
that they shall be recognized and it
will prevent them from being
molested Quran says hijab has been
prescribed for the woman so that it will
prevent them from being
molested and the Islamic Sharia says if
anyone rapes any woman he gets capital
punishment people me the capital
punishment
in this 20th century Islam is a barbaric
religion it's a ruthless
law it's a barbaric
religion do you know America which
happens to be the country which is
supposed to be most advanced it has one
of the highest rate of
rape according to the statistic it says
that on an average every day more than
1,900 females are being raped every day
every 1.3 minute one f is raped since
the time I'm in this Auditorium it's
more than 2 and a half hours how many
rapes may have taken place how many more
than 100 in America I'm asking you a
question if you implement the Islamic
Sharia in America that is every man when
he looks at a woman he should lower his
gaze the woman should be properly
dressed up in the
hijab and after that if any man rapes
capital punishment I asking a question
will the rate of rape increase will will
it remain the same or will it
decrease it will decree the Practical
law you implement the Sharia and you get
results and I've asked this question to
non-muslims that suppose someone rapes
unfortunately your wife or your mother
and if you are made the judge and if the
rapist is BN in front of you what
punishment will you give and believe me
all of them said we'll put him to death
someone to the extent of saying we will
torture him to death so why do you have
the double standards someone dap
somebody else's wife capital punishment
is barbar law someone rapes your wife
you want to give him capital punishment
why these double standards and do you
know in India according to the
statistics of crime Bureau it says that
every 54 minute one case of rape is
reported in India how many taking place
every few minutes maybe one case and no
wonder the home minister of India El
adwani you know what he said it came in
headlines of times of
India
headline what it says that adwani adwani
puts a death rap for rapes and
recommends an amendment in the law
headlines in times of India 20th of
October 10 days back on Tuesday one day
before 27th of October 1998 he said that
he wants death penalty for the
rapist
alhamdulillah what Islam has said 14
years ago elani is saying that and I
congrat him for that I'm not here to
promote any political party I'm not a
politician but if someone speaks the
truth I have to appreciate
it and if you implement this surely the
rate of rape will diminish maybe the
next home minister May implement the
Islamic hijab here also so inshallah the
rape will be completely abolished they
coming closer to Islam I appreciate
it come to comment terms between us and
you Mr realized that rape is increasing
in India and he rightly recommended that
the law should be amended and death
penalty should be put for the rapist and
I'm for it I'm the first Indian to
support
him so if you analyze Islam besides
speaking good things it shows you a way
how to achieve that state of goodness
therefore I say that Islam unlike other
religion we speak good things it shows
you a way how to achieve goodness so
therefore if I have to follow a religion
I would follow a religion which speaks
good things and shows you a way how to
achieve that good things therefore it is
rightly said in Surah Al Imran 3 verse
number
19l the only religion acceptable sight
of Allah subhana wa taala is the person
who submits the will to Allah subhana
tala yes you can put forward your
question brother my name is man Raa my
first question is under the name
Universal Brotherhood you are
advertising Islam and on the basis of
that please define your terms when you
are saying that Universal Brotherhood
you should under the name Universal
Brotherhood Brotherhood you should
accept Brotherhood to all whether
Muslims that is follower of Islam and
non-muslims which you say kafir who
don't otherwise C the term Muslim
Brotherhood it will be
okay the brother asked a question that
in the name of universal Brotherhood I'm
promoting Islam suppose if I have to say
that know best cloth I'm promoting best
cloth market and suppose Raymond has to
be the best cloth so it's a fact I'm
promoting Raymonds if Raymond's company
is best anyway I don't get any cut from
raymen that's an example I'm not a
dealer of renss but if I say the best
cloth is Rond and if the talk is which
is the best cloth I have to speak about
that I'm giving a talk on who is the
best doctor in the world and if I have
to take a person name XY Z and if he's
the best doctor I'm promoting him yes so
similarly Universal Brotherhood I'm
telling you that Islam is a religion
which speaks about Universal Brotherhood
and shows you a way to achieve it
regarding a question that in Universal
Brotherhood can you call Muslim and
non-muslim as brother or only Muslims as
brothers the universal brother of Islam
is all human beings are your brothers I
made it very clear in my talk I'm not
mining with words I'm very clear maybe
it may have slipped you may not have
heard it start my talk in h chap 49
ver3
that oh humankind we have created you
from a single pair of male and female
and have divided you into Nations and
tribes so that you shall recognize each
other not that you shall despise each
other and the most honored in the sight
of Allah is the person who has tawa who
has righteousness who has piety who has
God Consciousness in the Universal
Brotherhood are all human beings the
person who has got pety is one have tawa
or
righteousness I've got two brothers one
is a good person actually have got one
brother only but suppose I have two
brothers one is a medical doctor like
this brother he's treating the patient
Etc Cur and the other brother is a Dun
he's a rapist both are my brothers who
is a better brother a brother who's a
doctor and treats the people and doesn't
cause harm to the society the other
brother he's my brother but he's not a
good brother of mine similarly all human
beings are my brothers but those who are
closer to me are those who have tawa who
has righteousness who has piety anyone
who has piety who has righteousness who
has God Consciousness is closer to me
it's very clear I've sent my talk and I
repeat it hope that answerers the
question you have
differentiated Hinduism Islamic and
Christianity in all three religions
there are good things for Brotherhood
you have not explain Brotherhood in
Hinduism Brotherhood in
Christianity the brother said that I
spoken good things about Islam Universal
Brotherhood I haven't spoken good things
about Hinduism and
Christianity I didn't speak certain good
things I didn't speak everything about
Brotherhood in Hinduism and Christianity
because people may not be able to digest
it here this thing what I'm saying
people can't
digest I have to be patient I know
Christianity I've studied the Bible I
studied the Hindu scriptures if I speak
on that that I'm not here to create a
rift what I'm here to talk about the
commonalities so what is common spoke
Hinduism says Don't drop Christianity
say don't Rob don't Mo don't rap fine
other things on
brotherhood do you know just a sample
I'm giving you Jesus Christ peace be
upon himself said it's mentioned in the
gospel of Matthew chapter number 10
verse number 5-6 it says I'm quoting
chapter number verse number quoting
there's no two doubts about it he told
the apostles that go not into the way of
the G Gentiles but rather go to the lost
sheep of the House of Israel who are the
Gentiles the non-jews the Hindus the
Christian we are the
Gentiles don't throw Pearls Before pigs
he calls us as pigs am I going to speak
about that Jesus Christ peace be upon
says in the gospel of Matthew chapter
number 15 verse number 24 he says that I
have not been sent but to the lost sheep
of the House of Israel I'm quoting
chapter number verse number so this
means that that religion is only meant
for the Jews not for the whole
universe in other religions they believe
in monasticism in monasticism if you
have to come closer to God you have to
renounce the world you have to renounce
the world most of the major religions
Hinduism says that Christianity says
that to come closer to God you have to
renounce the world Quran says in Surah
had chapter 57 ver number 27 that it's
against
monasticism monasticism is not allowed
in Islam our beloved Prophet said
there's no monasticism it's mentioned s
bukari volume number seven in the book
of nikah chapter number three Hadith
number four oh young people Whoever has
the means to get married should get
married Hadith says that if I agree that
if you renounce the world you come
closer to almighty God and if every
human being renounces the world today
then within a span of 100 to 150 years
there will not be a single human being
alive in this world if everyone
practices this law throughout the world
is the universal Brotherhood therefore
brother I'm only come to talk about the
good points unless you want to have
knowledge about other religions it's my
job I have to speak the truth Quran says
in chter number 17 verse number
81 when TR is falsehood falsehood
perishes for falsehood is by its nature
bound to perish hope that answer the
question I'm advate
M you said in your speech that uh God is
Allah is imagess and formless as started
in Hinduism then why Muslims during HUD
pilgrimage they worship holy shr as a
Hindu they
worship that's a very good question the
brother has posed that if almighty God
has got no image in Islam Allah subhana
tala no form then why do the Muslims
they worship the holy is referring to
the Caba in Hal pilgrimage whether it's
a misconception no muslim ever worship
the Caba it's a misconception among the
non-muslims that we Muslims we worship
the
Caba no muslim worship the Caba we only
worship Allah subhana wa ta'ala who we
cannot see in this world what we do is
thata is
theah in Arabic means the direction CA
is the because we Muslims we believe in
unity always Unity for example if you
want to pray to almighty God Allah
subhana wa tala if we have to offer
Salah some may say let's face the North
some may say let's face South some may
say East some may say West where do we
face we believe in unity so for unity
all the Muslims throughout the world
they asked to face in the direction of
the that is the Caba it's a direction we
don't worship it and the first people
who do the world map were the Muslims
and when the Muslims do the world map
they do with the South Pole on top and
north pole down and Caba was in the
center the Western came and they turned
the map upside down North Pole on top
South Pole down alhamdulillah yet the
Caba is in the center Mecca is in the
center and since Mecca in the center any
Muslim in any part of the world if he's
staying in north of Caba he faces toward
the South if he's staying in the south
of Caba he faces toward the north all
the Muslims toward the world they face
in One Direction Caba is the is the
direction no muslim ever worships it and
when we go for Hajj to the pilgrimage we
circum ambulate around the Caba we
circum ambulate around the Caba because
everyone knows that all circles have
only one Center so we circum ambulate
around the Caba to testify that there is
only one God not because we worship it
and the statement of the second Khalifa
of Islam pleas with him he said it's
mentioned in s
Muslim in the book of Hajj volume number
two he said pleas with him that I am
kissing the black stone that is
theaba only because my Prophet kissed it
otherwise this black stone can neither
harm me neither can it benefit me the
second khif of Islam of Islam with him
he made it clear for eternity that no
muslim ever worship the black stone it
can neither benefit us neither can it
harm us
and the best example is that during the
time of the Prophet the sahabas the
companion of the Prophet they even stood
on Thea and gave the aan aan is a call
for prayers people stood on the CA and
gave the aan I asking you which Idol
worshipper will ever stand on the idly
worships so these are sufficient proof
that no muslim ever worship the Caba
Caba is the kah and we worship only
Allah subhana wa ta'ala who we cannot
see with eyes hope the answerers the
question
I'm Dr vas a medical
practitioner we came
here for having views on universal
Brotherhood we did not come here for a
bodik on
Islam I would request you to tell
us about
Brotherhood in this world now this is
universal Brotherhood I would like to
know whether there are brothers in other
parts of the universe we have brothers
in India so we talk of Indian
Brotherhood and how Brotherhood in this
country has affected the history of this
country during last 100
years the brother asked a very good
question a very relevant question he
said that you know he has come here to
hear about Universal Brotherhood and
what I spoke is about the Brotherhood of
the world only and are we Brothers in
other parts of the
universe B is a doctor
alhamdulillah and if you heard my talk
if you pay attention to it brother I
said that we believe in almighty God who
is the lord of the
worlds mean lord of the words means lord
of the universe besides this word
brother of the universe this India yes
brother yes if you hear my
answer
I'll reply to and then I come to your
question most welcome I'm here I will
reply to everyone inshallah first I'll
just reply to the elderly gentleman he
has asked a question it's my pleasure to
reply he said talk about Brotherhood
that's the Brotherhood and Universal
Brotherhood means not only Brotherhood
of this world but of the worlds of the
whole universe and according to the
Glorious Quran in Sur chapter number 42
verse number 29 it says that Allah
subhana wa ta'ala has created the
heavens and the Earth and has put
creatures between them that means the
Quran says that there are living
creatures beside this world there are
living creatures besides this world
science hasn't reached that far to prove
that there is life besides this Earth
You Know scientists they sending rockets
and satellites and spaceships to try and
prove their life on Mars Etc it's not
established they say there are high
chances but the Quran says there is life
besides this Earth and I believe in it
so Universal Brotherhood doesn't only
means Brotherhood in this world it means
Brotherhood even in the other worlds as
you rightly said even Brotherhood in
India even brother in India throughout
the world and for this Brotherhood to
Prevail if you heard my talk I don't
repeat the full talk again that there
should be a moral conduct that no human
being should kill any other human being
he should not Rob he should give charity
he should love his
neighbors he should should not back
bite he should see to it that when he
sleeps with a full stomach even his
neighbors is fed well he should see to
it that he does not have alcohol alcohol
prevents the Brotherhood to Prevail in
the world he should not backbite he
should not slander anyone all these
things promote Universal Brotherhood not
only in India not only in the world in
the full universe may be possible that
you did not pay attention to some
portions of my talk my talk
alhamdulillah was focused on the topic
and it did Cover India America full
world as well as the universe and this
can only take place and all the
religions if you believe in the concept
that the creator of all the human beings
of all the creatures whether in India or
whether in America or whether outside
this world is one almighty God and all
the religions basically speak in belief
of one God which I discussed in detail
for more details for concept of God I've
given this talk concept of God major
religion it speaks more about the
concept of God in other religions like
sism and parm Etc and it deals in detail
if a person wants to have more knowledge
on how it can Prevail you can aail of my
C concept of God major religion it's
available for sale outside in the fire
now we have the respected Advocate
prabakar ra Hegde presenting his
impressions as a chief
guest
Dr Jakir n and
friends I deem it my privilege to be
here this
morning to hear this talk by Dr Zakir
nyak the president of the Islamic
Research
Foundation and I was really impressed by
it I am a Hindu
but don't go to the
temples neither
introduce religion in my politics I
belong to the
Congress here those who came to hear Dr
hakir Nik should have seen and realized
that he is a person who has to do with
Islam religion and he will speak only on
Islam religion and I feel it very
unhappy that some of the people who
introduced religion in politics tried to
obstruct his speech by asking
inconvenient
questions may I ask them a question have
they read Vedas have they read
upas have you read any other the
religious scripts or because it is
convenient to be a Hindu to come in
power they want to caners religion my
submission is most respectful submission
is here I came to hear a Muslim scholar
on the topic what his religion wants to
convey whether I accept or I don't
accept is another thing
but uh I will tell
you that the Hindu religion is there for
thousands of
years and Islam religion has come 1400
years back it is a religion which has
come up after seeing the torture done by
other religions on the people of the
world and therefore that is a religion
which is more
socialistic and has given more the
method also how to implement I remember
in 1978 when I contested from Tana from
this buy I met my friend isak n Advocate
and he gave me the translation of Quran
in English which I had gone through
before I contested election I still
remember to have read the contribution
of the Muslim in the Freedom Movement of
India a book written by author and I
will tell my friends here who are
talking about the religion and Hinduism
that it was the wahhabis who first stood
against the British in
1833 it is not the Hindu that collected
together to fight the Battle of
Independence it was the Muslim who
fought the Battle of it is unfortunate
that we don't both of us don't go
together it is unfortunate for this
country that but it is really equally
unfortunate that some persons want to
Canvas it and make it a point in
politics to introduce religion I'm
really impressed by the speech I have
learned a lot
not that I agree with whatever he has
said but it's a way of thinking and
certainly deserves serious consideration
and I am thankful to him I thank you
[Applause]
all may I now
request respected Advocate K hingorani
to present his presidential address Dr
nyak my
friends I'm really
honored to have been asked to Pride over
this
function though of course in a vacancy
fing
manner but even
then I'm really proud to be here and
associated with the thoughts which are
expressed by Dr
n I'm not an expert on any religion
either mine or of Dr zits but one thing
I can claim
that I was born in a place where Islam
was
first brought in to the shores of India
I come from Province known as
s for the first time in my life I have
heard a Muslim scholar though I heard so
many Muslim
mananas who can understand and really
read the things comparatively not only
from an exclusive point of view as
normal nor it is misunderstood by us
that Islam is a exclusive
religion only meant for compartmental
people who believe in certain things and
who disbelieve in other things when he
said that we should bring out the
commonalities the common things between
the different religions first and then
disagree upon the points which we do not
agree upon I think this is one of the
best statement that I have heard in my
life once I had heard Dr radak Krishnan
speak speaking in the same men on the
comparative religions of India and after
that after about 50 years I heard Dr
naak to speak that there are certain
common
things and really there are certain
common things because when he spoke
about the tawa is Arabic word I think
that is the
pronunciations and he said it is God
Consciousness I was reminded of my own
shivm Kashmir shivm which also talks
about the God consciousness as being the
fundamental force in life that
everything emanates from it it is not
born it is not created it is not come
out of the womb of a woman it is self
evident swu it is there in existence
since time immemorial when the time had
not started Shiva was there and when he
talked about God Consciousness I was
reminded of that Hinduism as such is not
restricted only to vanta the four vas
are also very difficult to understand of
course he has studied them I bow before
his calliness and I feel that what he
says is correct and I quite agree with
him that Hindu word is a geographical
connotation and I'm proud to say that it
came into existence because of the Sy
when the foreigners came to India they
tried to cross the indust river
especially
sander and he said that it is synu it it
is it was it was told to him that the
name name of this river is Hindu and
being an Iranian or a unani he could not
pronounce Hindu he said it is Hindu half
the Hindu they call Seven Rivers as ha
Hindu Seven Rivers so I'm proud that the
word Hindu has come because the sin was
there and really in India we
need this type of thing because much
misconception has gone there that
Muslims are terrorist somebody asked a
question I mean I think this is the most
comprehensible statement that was ever
made that Muslims are terrorists this is
all nonsense and it should be curved and
it is because of this that we feel that
we are so insecure in this country you
you cannot treat a Muslim as a terrorist
because he's a Muslim he's a
fundamentalist if he's a fundamentalist
of the color of Dr n i welcome him I'll
welcome him to my
house and you must also know of course I
have to talk about these things which I
never wanted because when I came I had
an spiritual experience by his talk but
then recently 2 3 days back there was a
news in the paper that the front man for
the person in Dubai is a
Hindu I'm referring to Dr rames Sharma
he is the man who they claim to be the
person who coordinated all the works of
Da sitting
now whom will you say a Hindu is a
terrorist or a Muslim is a
terrorist therefore please forget these
things forget about Muslims have been
there bad kings from Muslims were there
bad kings from Hindus were there and
they need to be improved but you can't
say or hold anything against Dr Nik for
what Alin Ki did in his times or what or
did to his brothers or what Akbar did
these things are nonsense these are
facts of History which you to gloss over
you want to live in this country try to
understand the common things between the
parties bring them out I'll request Dr n
to go into Hindu congregations and try
to make them understand what Islam
stands for and as for my personal belief
is concerned I think Islam is one of the
greatest things that has happened to
this world thank you very much for
giving me this honor and hearing me
out Muslim who is better in speech than
one who invites people to the way of thy
Lord Works righteousness and says I'm of
those who bow to the will of Allah those
who say I'm a Muslim so when anyone POS
the question what are you you should say
I'm a Muslim